sébastien nadeau bonjour merci de
répondre à nos questions pourquoi cette
vente à zagreb pourquoi maintenant et en
quoi la croatie était là stratégique
écoutez d'abord florence parly l'a dit
c'est une bonne nouvelle que caïn autres
pays européens achètent du matériel
français
cela dit la question qu'on devrait se
poser c'est pourquoi c'est pas cette
situation là à chaque fois ensuite si on
les questions diplomatiques bien
évidemment à mesure que du matériel
européen est répartie sur le territoire
européen
on ne peut que s'en satisfaire et la
croatie et en grande proximité de la
méditerranée vous aurez compris que sur
les questions du bassin méditerranéen
notamment vis-à-vis de la turquie
ça a un intérêt stratégique manifeste
justement j'allais venir puisqu'il ya eu
une vente récemment également à la grèce
la grèce
opposé à la turquie au sujet des
hydrocarbures en méditerranée orientale
quels sont les arrière pensées de la
france avec tout cela je crois que c'est
assez simple à comprendre
erdogan est un chef d'état qui
fonctionne sur le rapport de force à
partir de données assez évidente on met
en position de quoi répondre si besoin
elle sur cette question du rapport de
force dans différents points qui sont
relativement opérationnel rapidement
vis-à-vis d'intervention que pourrait
faire la turquie en méditerranée et donc
c'est un signal d'un casier alors
d'abord ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
qu'effectivement il en quelques années
mais c'est s'aider des avions qui sont
pleinement performants sont vraiment
dans la pleine maturité de leurs
performances donc ensuite mire est-ce
que c'est vivant d'avoir des avions
ça fait partie de la dissuasion c'était
quelque chose d'important et j'aimerais
que ce soit effectivement la vente
30 rafale à l'egypte récemment a été
rendue possible par un prêt de dix ans
en grande partie garanti par l'état
français
selon le site d'investigation disclose
c'est donc le contribuable qui pourrait
payer l'ardoisé ainsi l'egypte ne
respectaient pas les engagements les
engagements pris pourquoi tout cela
selon vous est-ce que l'exportation a du
mal à trouver ses clients écoutez moi
pour moi c'est un succès diplomatique ce
dont on vient de parler
en revanche sur la question commerciale
ça reste avec bien des interrogations et
vous l'avez relevé juste avant on vend
des rafales à l'egypte mais on ne sait
pas à quel moment et si et qu'elle ment
pas on va récupérer
par ailleurs les monte en l'air chaud
est une c'est pas l'argent on fait
rentrer dans les caisses de l'état
français est là la même question se pose
avec la croatie plus d'un milliard
d'euros à ce moment de crise ça
questionne sur la réalité d'un retour
financier les les invendus en armement
est ce que c'est une force de
négociation géopolitique
oui ça fait partie ça fait partie d'un
ensemble bien évidemment la france a
besoin son industrie militaire pouvoir
montre un certain nombre d'appareils
et puis par ailleurs vous poser la
question économiquement finalement de
cet aspect ce qu'il faut voir c'est que
on est en train d'avancer vers le ska
qu'est ce que c'est le cas c'est le
nouvel appareil militaire du futur avec
l'allemagne avec l'espagne et c'est vrai
que de ce côté il ya aussi bien des
inquiétudes vous savez moi je suis
député à toulouse et la recherche et les
développements concernant le ska est en
train de partir en allemagne en espagne
et ailleurs
donc
il ya des enjeux qui sont extrêmement
importants du point de vue de l'emploi
et du point de vue commercial et cette
annonce ne répond pas à ces enjeux pour
revenir au delà de l'aspect économique
et social avec les emplois pour revenir
sur le domaine et géopolitiques et c'est
donc notamment pas forcément pour parler
de la croatie
c'est ce qui se passe en ce moment mais
ce qui s'est passé récemment avec avec
l'egypte les 30 rafale vendu au caire on
sait qu'il ya pas très longtemps il ya
eu le conflit israélo palestinien la
france qu'elle a proposé une résolution
au conseil de sécurité de l'onu avec la
jordanie et avec l'egypte est ce que le
fait de vendre des avions de chasse un
peu avant et derrière se positionner
comme ça on a vu d'ailleurs très
récemment
halte ici à l'elysée est ce que tout
cela est lié au final je vous vends des
avions je fais un prêt garanti par
l'état mais derrière on veut un retour
de manière géopolitique
alors vous avez raison de relever que la
géopolitique et la diplomatie c'est un
jeu de dominos quant à la manière dont
la france
influence l'egypte à travers des ventes
de rafale
si vous me posez cette question
j'aimerais bien qu'elle influence
l'egypte sur la question des droits de
l'homme et pour l'instant force est de
constater que de ce côté là le président
emmanuel macron étant l'échec et n'a pas
réussi à faire venir le président
égyptien vers plus de clémence vis-à-vis
des opposants politiques qui sont très
très nombreux en prison dans des
situations qui sont tout à fait
inacceptables de la part d'un pays avec
lequel on commerce des armes
merci beaucoup sébastien nadeau d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes député de haute garonne et que
vous êtes membre du groupe parlementaire
liberté et territoires membres de la
commission des affaires étrangères